some of the sports venues in las vegas
were hanging on the words of what the
governor was saying earlier today
owners want to see fans back sports
director chris matthews joining us with
more on that angle tonight chris
well thank you denise you think of all
the venues here lost and all the revenue
loss because of the sports shutdown
estimated to be close to two billion
dollars in economic losses
so when will fans be allowed back and
the next big event of course is the las
vegas motor speedway
the race out there let's get right to
general manager of the speedway for his
reaction today
chris powell now chris just three weeks
away from your big race here is that
going to be enough time to get local
health officials aware and maybe
signed off on a plan to get some fans
back well chris we're happy to say that
we've already submitted our plan to
local authorities and the state
authorities and we feel very confident
that
it's a very good plan and it will get
approved and that we'll be able to have
the
20 percent that uh that was was
designated today by governor sysolak so
we're
most appreciative of that and uh if
there's any point i'd like to make
tonight is
it is that for any fan who chooses to
come to nascar at las vegas motor
speedway in march
we can guarantee that we will do
everything in our power
to make it as safe uh an atmosphere as
is possible we will
do all the social and physical
distancing we'll be cleaning and
cleaning and cleaning
and we'll do everything in our power to
make sure that this is not the kind of
thing that will cause
a problem going forward for our venue or
anyone else's because
we take safety very very seriously all
right final question chris let me just
ask you about the 20
is that i mean your place seats about
100 000 out there is 20
acceptable at least for now
well given that back in september we
were at zero percent
we're happy for anything we can get
certainly we'd like you know if
if the race were a week later march 15th
we would be up to
35 or 50 and so uh that's unfortunate
that we missed by
a week and maybe the governor can
revisit that one for us but without
question we can make it work and
and we can make a lot of fans happy and
i know that people are
ready to get back out and ready to enjoy
all the things that our community has to
offer and i certainly believe that
nascar is one of those things that
people really look forward to especially
here in las vegas
and so we're we're looking forward to
putting on a safe and and
exciting event here not only for our
speedway but for our community
exactly thank you very much chris powell
we appreciate that kind of sends a
little countenance there and your face
has changed a little bit
that nascar rates coming up march 5th
through the 7th and it could open the
door for other events vegas golden
knights bringing some fans back perhaps
the runner rebels ufc boxing and of
course the pac-12 mountain west west
coast
and whack basketball tournaments in
march brian